[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
i'm amur i lead developer relations at
google cloud
what's developer relations you might ask
we are engineers
who love talking to people who are
hands-on
that includes developers operators data
engineers data scientists
any technical practitioner who makes the
information technology world
go round we are constantly inspired by
and in awe of what you do
we succeed by supporting you along the
journey
to modernize your applications and
innovate
ever since google cloud started working
with you we learned a lot
about the challenges of building and
operating enterprise workloads
while also dealing with the business
imperative to constantly innovate
for instance we see teams struggling
with these four problem areas
first they are constantly occupied with
lots of non-productive repetitive tasks
and in many cases reinventing the wheel
for things that have been figured out
many times over second
the businesses are afraid of frequently
updating their high value workloads due
to stability and security concerns
which significantly hinders the rate of
innovation
third they struggle to keep up with all
the mandates around compliance auditing
security availability
you name it and fourth
it's almost impossible to write
applications once then have them run
anywhere
whether that be on premises in the cloud
or at the edge
and as you know this isn't about whether
you're in the cloud or not
many of you have made the transition to
the cloud already but you still face
these challenges
we want to help you significantly
accelerate the speed with which you
solve
create and innovate we do this in three
ways
first we think it's important to
automate as much as possible
this means eliminating repeatable tasks
in pursuit of
important objectives such as secure by
default
monitoring by default canary testing and
continuous integration and delivery
in other words let's stop reinventing
the wheel
second we want to increase your
productivity
we know that everyone comes from
different backgrounds and works in
different environments with different
tools
we embrace this diversity by supporting
your favorite open source
frameworks and enterprise software
applications and we do this
as you see in this talk not just on the
infrastructure side with efforts like
kubernetes
but also for developers by supporting
code editors like intellij
and visual studio code third
you need portability options for where
your workloads run
our goal is to enable you to write your
applications once
then have them run anywhere with minimal
to no code changes
while transparently carrying over all
the security
governance and observability
requirements
to demonstrate how google cloud helps
you with all of this
my colleagues and i will highlight the
key parts of a journey from migration
to innovation we will use a sample
financial application that we call
demo bank a traditional two-tier
business application
that simulates a bank it's already been
migrated from virtual machines to
containers running in google cloud
what's next in the mobilization journey
for demo bank
let's talk to my colleague megan a
developer relations engineer for anthous
to find out
hi megan great to see you hi amber
i heard you run on coffee so before you
start would you like some
absolutely here you go
thank you let's take a look at how demo
bank is running in containers on anthos
i'm starting in the google cloud console
where i've deployed the app onto a
kubernetes engine cluster
in my project i actually have multiple
clusters running for development
staging and production plus a cluster
running in aws
which i've registered to the anthos
dashboard
this aws cluster is running some legacy
workloads that
we're trying to migrate into google but
for now we can see the status of that
cluster in the anthos dashboard
let's take a look at the production
cluster to see what's running
demo bank is a two-tier web app with a
front end and two back-ends
one back-end is written in python the
other in java
the back-ends are monolithic each with
an embedded sql database
as someone who works with platform
administrators a lot something i really
like about anthos
is the observability you get right out
of the box let's navigate to antho
service mesh to check it out
when i migrated demo bank from virtual
machines to containers running on anthos
each workload here the front end the
account service
has antho service mesh enabled a service
mesh
tracks all the requests flowing through
the app and generates metrics like
request throughput and latency
i didn't have to refactor the workloads
to get these metrics
it all just works and the result is that
i can see a live network topology
diagram
of the application at runtime so as an
admin or a platform engineer
the anthos dashboard is like my copilot
showing me what's happening with the app
from this dashboard i can also dial into
one of these services to view metrics
and service health
from there i can set up service level
objectives or slos to ensure that the
app is meeting any required thresholds
for availability
and performance antho service mesh is
also integrated into google cloud
monitoring
so i can create a single dashboard to
see all the metrics relevant to the
application
from the app code level to database
metrics all the way down to the
underlying infrastructure
and because i just migrated this app
from vms to containers
these dashboards are really useful and
will help me figure out how to
right-size my workloads and set
appropriate resource requests
overall moving existing workloads into
anthos helps me gain deep visibility
into this app
at all levels of the stack catch you
later armor
thanks megan this looks great however
this is not the end of the modernization
journey
modernization is a continuous journey to
improve your ability to deliver quality
solution
easier faster and more securely
after the migration to anthos demo bank
is now more secure available and
responsive
but next they need to accelerate the
rate with which they deliver
improvements and innovations
to meet the ever increasing customer
expectations
in their case demo bank wants to expand
its online capabilities
and serve more lines of business to do
this we can
adopt a microservices architecture
versus two-tier
so that we can scale out just the parts
that need it
and feature teams can own individual
services to release more quickly and
frequently
to help with this modernization journey
google cloud provides
end-to-end development tooling which
allows you to focus on your business
logic
and the automation takes care of filling
in the rest for you
furthermore you can iterate more quickly
with the confidence of knowing that
automated observability
will detect production issues early for
you
let's now talk to daniel a software
engineer working on spring boot
integrations for google cloud
and see how we can quickly develop a new
microservice using tools that you
are already familiar with
hey daniel we can't hear you try this
mic
oh thank you armor
[Music]
so to modernize our application let's
try refactoring the authentication
features of demo bank to a separate
microservice
this area of our app has experienced a
lot of growth and increased traffic
normally this task would be complex but
we're going to take advantage of a
variety of google cloud managed services
for less maintenance and better
availability and also use various tools
to make use of cloud
much easier for the new microservice we
will use cloud sql for our database
and we'll configure it for high
availability with the click of a button
next let's start writing some code our
development team uses java and prefers
the spring boot framework
we'll create a spring boot service from
start.spring.io to generate some starter
code for this project
select gcp support as a dependency which
allows us to easily integrate with
google cloud services
now as we write code we're able to just
focus on the business logic
there will be some points where we can
leverage more cloud services
in addition to the database for example
we use a private key to encrypt
authentication tokens
previously this key was stored in an
on-premises secret store like hashicorp
vault
on google cloud you can continue to use
vault if you need to but for this demo
we'll switch to google secret manager
which is a secure way of storing secrets
on the cloud so you don't have to manage
the infrastructure yourself
we can use spring cloud gcp libraries to
access the secret through the
application's configuration
without any extra code spring cloud gcp
is one of the many libraries and tools
maintained by google
in partnership with the open source
community also as part of the
modernization effort
we'll trace service calls have
centralized logging
and generate custom metrics using spring
cloud gcp
all of these features can be added to
our app through configuration alone
so this is the big idea we don't have to
write any extra code to do all this
and with minimal configuration you can
now see in application traces in cloud
trace and clicking show logs will show
you the logs associated with each
request
you can also see jvm and application
level metrics
exported to cloud monitoring and explore
them in a dashboard
now because our application has no
custom code to access google cloud
services
it's portable across hybrid environments
if you need to deploy the same
application on-premises
simply change the configuration without
modifying the code
and similarly an on-premises application
can easily adopt google cloud services
through just configuration let's test
everything before we ship it
for cloud sql to start the postgresql
instance with data for testing
we can use a third-party open source
project called test containers
now the database container is
automatically started when we run an
integration test
for cloud databases such as firestore or
cloud spanner
you can use our local emulators we'll
use a tool called jib to containerize
our java application
another alternative is a build pack
which can achieve a similar outcome
these tools let you use best practices
without needing deep expertise in
container tools
let's also run our application locally
to test it out i can easily do this with
the cloud code extension in either
intellij or vs code ide
and launch the entire stack in minicube
so i can see everything working
end to end on my local machine if i make
a change to the code now
cloud code will automatically redeploy
my changes into the local environment
alright everything looks good i'm ready
to check in the code and see how it gets
pushed to production
back to you armor thanks daniel that was
awesome
as daniel showed you google cloud
provides comprehensive end-to-end
development tooling
namely ide extensions integrations with
widely used frameworks
and fully managed cloud services this
significantly accelerates your
productivity so you can realize the true
potential of application monetization
while using skills and tools you already
know and have
so what's next it looks like we're ready
to deploy daniel's new service into our
anthos environment
google cloud is here to help you with
that as we increase
the number of demo bank services it's
important that we build consistency
and automation in our processes this is
where continuous integration and
deployment
commonly known as ci cd comes in
cicd helps you to quickly confidently
and safely roll out updates for many
services
in parallel this means you can innovate
with lower risk and higher velocity
let's bring megan back to show you how
google cloud supports you to release
new services in a secure and low risk
way
hi megan before you start have some more
coffee
thank you armor now let's take a look at
daniel's pull request in the demo bank
repository
the repo uses github actions for
continuous integration
here on daniel's branch we have
integration and functional tests running
to make sure that daniel's code changes
are compatible with the other demo bank
apis
once i review daniel's code i can go
ahead and hit merge
doing this will automatically trigger a
release pipeline
running in google cloud build this
pipeline builds the demo bank container
images
then uses binary authorization to sign
all the images
this helps us ensure that any container
image deployed to gke
is safe and trusted once this pipeline
completes another cloud build pipeline
starts up
this is our continuous deployment
pipeline which takes the release
deployment manifest
configured with the new image tags and
applies it to the production gke cluster
then from our development slack channel
cloud build sends us a notification that
the new service has successfully
deployed
now that the container's running i can
control how traffic gets sent to this
new service
to ensure a safe rollout because the
existing account service is still
serving requests
i'm going to keep it running in the
cluster for now but
i can use service mesh to rewrite http
requests
from the account service monolith to the
new user service
with no code changes and on top of that
send only a small percentage of that
traffic to daniel's user service
then i can return to the antho service
mesh dashboard to view metrics for how
the user service is faring in production
then incrementally send more traffic to
it once i know it's healthy
i can even take it a step further and
configure security policies for this new
service
anthos config management is a tool that
allows you to push policy configuration
to
a git repository and automatically sync
those policies down to your clusters
this can help you apply org-wide
policies across many services at once
because we're dealing with the banking
application data security is really
important
so one thing i can do is create a policy
to encrypt
all http traffic across all the demo
bank workloads
once anthous config management syncs
this policy from git
i can return to the service mesh
dashboard to see the encryption status
for all of our services
here i can now see that traffic to
daniel's new user service
is encrypted with mutual tls
authentication so
that's how i use google cloud to put a
new service into production on anthos
over to you armor thanks megan for
showing us the cicd process for demo
bank services
i think this is super cool for several
reasons
first it's really compelling how safety
and risk reduction
are top of mind throughout the entire
release process
we ensure the safety of the deployment
itself its ability to serve traffic
without
errors and the authenticity of the
release artifact through binary
authorization
second notice how the automation
supported by cloud build
github actions and anthous policies help
build that safety
automation reduces human input which in
turn
reduces the possibility of human error
this allows us to deploy
new code changes several times per day
confident that for instance
the user data encryption will
automatically be maintained
a very key point of this entire talk is
that safety
speeds up innovation and increases room
for creativity
now that we're here we are in a good
position to take advantage of more of
what google cloud
offers in this case let's see what
machine learning can do for our
financial services workloads
let's call sara hi amer
having our application and data in
google cloud allows us to easily tap
into other parts of our platform
in our app finding a way to flag
fraudulent transactions quickly
will save everyone a lot of time and
money machine learning is a great fit
for this i'll use bigquery automl tables
and ai platform notebooks to build our
solution
and i'll use the explainability tools in
automl to understand how our model is
making predictions
as a data scientist i'd like to do my
data preprocessing from a notebook
environment where i can interact
directly with bigquery data
i'll do this with cloud ai platform
notebooks we're using a publicly
available bigquery data set of credit
card transactions to train our model
for each transaction we have data on the
time amount
and a few other variables we see that
the original data set is heavily
imbalanced
which could negatively affect the
quality of our model to reduce the
imbalance
i'm using a technique called down
sampling to take all of the examples
from our minority class
fraud and a random sample of our
majority class
while still maintaining a diverse sample
of the non-fraud data
next i am saving the updated data set to
a new bigquery table
this data is now ready to be sent to a
model to build
train and deploy our model i'll use
automl tables
it'll let me do all these things without
writing any model code
with automl tables i can train an ml
model while keeping my data in bigquery
when i press train automl takes care of
transforming our data into the correct
format
and finding the best model type for our
task fortunately
automl has some optimization methods to
handle the remaining data imbalance
after down sampling
here i'm choosing to optimize our
model's performance on our less common
class during training
now that our model's trained let's look
at some evaluation metrics
the confusion matrix tells us the
percentage from each class that our
model predicted correctly
this model reached 86 accuracy with no
false positives on our fraud class which
is looking pretty good
rather than writing our own algorithm of
hard-coded rules for catching fraudulent
transactions
we built a model to do this by finding
patterns in our data
even with a high quality model it's
important to understand what led our
model to predict fraud
through the explainable ai integration
with automl tables
we can see which features our model is
relying on most to make a prediction
i can now deploy my model with one click
then i can get predictions in the ui or
with the automl prediction api
let's try it out we'll make a
transaction with this credit card and
see if our model flags it as fraud
looks like this is not a real credit
card yikes
oh wait this is a banking demo not a
banking demo
let's go back to the code
i'm making a request to the automl
tables prediction api for my notebook
to get a test prediction on our model
with feature attributions
in the api response we get the model's
prediction and the instance level
attribution values
indicating which features our model
relied on most to make this prediction
for my notebooks instance i can create a
new version of the data set
and even programmatically kick off model
retraining
let's train our model for more time and
see if automl is able to create a better
model
in addition to testing our deployed
model from a notebook we also want to
get predictions from our web app
we want to keep the client code simple
and handle calling the model and parsing
the prediction response on the server
i'll take the python code that calls our
deployed model and put it in cloud run
cloudrun lets me take code in any
language and deploy it in a scalable
container environment
without worrying about infrastructure
management
with two commands i can deploy the
container to cloudrun so that it's
triggered whenever a transaction is made
from our banking app
as we iterate on our python code and
model we can also make use of cloudrun's
traffic splitting feature
to serve new versions of our service to
a small percentage of users
to test out my cloud run service i'm
making a curl request to it here
although the service is deployed i'm
only charged for the time it's being
used since cloud run supports auto
scaling by default
this means it'll scale to zero when
there are no requests and just like that
from data pre-processing in bigquery to
deployed automl tables model
we built an end-to-end fraud detection
solution
with the right tools machine learning
really is a piece of cake
would you like some armor thanks sarah
that cakes looks delicious
i can't wait to taste it that was very
impressive
we just saw how sara applied flow
detection to our financial services
scenario using tools
she already knows i believe that every
industry could innovate around the kind
of cloud scale data analytics
and machine learning made easily
available to your data engineers
data scientists and analysts also
stepping back
as megan and daniel showed you we are
bringing to dev and ops
an integrated set of automated
capabilities that represent the
best of what googlers learned about code
workflows and tooling
over many years while developing our own
planet scale consumer services
the end result is that we make you as
productive as possible while
improving the quality of your software
and enabling faster
and safer release rates
we bring this to you through your
favorite open source and third-party
frameworks
enterprise applications tools and
languages meeting you where you are
so you can start solving immediately
with the skills and code you already
have
you saw megan use mthouse and cloud
build to deploy and operate
containerized applications in a safe
predictable way
this means developers can focus more on
the application logic
versus the infrastructure allowing them
to iterate at a faster rate
you saw daniel use sprint boot and
spring cloud gcp
to set up tracing logging and monitoring
with only configuration changes
this also means that your code is
portable to any cloud provider
on-premises or the edge and you so sara
go from raw data to a trained deployed
automl model
all without moving data from bigquery
this means you can train high quality
models
with less code allowing you to focus on
improving the predictions
and getting them faster to your end
users
to learn more we have the google cloud
certification program which allows you
to specialize in our products
in an industry recognized way we also
have our youtube channel
blogs and online tutorials authored by
many of our engineers at google
whether you are already using google
cloud or just starting
i hope we have inspired you on your
application
modernization and data powered
innovation journey
we are so excited to be working with you
let's get solving
now i can finally enjoy some of sarah's
delicious cake
[Music]
hi there this is the death video i'm
here to tell you a
very short story how gcp has made my
life easier to take one
[Applause]
[Music]
will run only takes five minutes to hide
my solution deployed
bigquery makes it possible to understand
analyze and even forecast our world a
planetary scale
gcp's data proc was not only having all
the applications that i needed
but it was extremely easy to fire up a
stack
in the cloud within a few seconds i once
had to set up a kubernetes cluster and
it took me
two whole days to get everything up and
running
now when i moved to google communities
engine it just took me
two minutes i really do love the cloud
share
it's so easy that you can focus
in what you want to do since receiving
the google professional
solution architect certification i was
able to help solve for our analytics
problems
i could not imagine if you have to build
everything from stress
today
you can unleash your creativity by using
what you want and what you like
making a complex choice being
it's absolutely magic okay so thanks
thanks
okay we've come to the end of my story
so raw credits now
bye